JENNY BROWN: So far on
Cloud Storage Bytes,
we've talked about
managing object data
through renaming,
moving, and deleting.
But there's another
facet of managing objects
that's equally important--
managing metadata.
Today we'll take a
look at what metadata
is available in a Cloud Storage
object and how it's used.
Let's get started.
[CHEERFUL MUSIC]
Metadata identifies properties
of a Cloud Storage object
and specifies how
the object should
be handled when it's accessed.
Metadata exists as
key/value pairs.
The mutability of
metadata varies.
Some metadata you
can edit at any time.
Some metadata you can
only set at the time
the object is created, and some
metadata you can only view.
So, first, let's talk
about editable metadata.
There are two
categories of metadata
that are editable by users--
fixed-key metadata
and custom metadata.
With fixed-key metadata,
the keys are set,
but you can specify a value.
With custom metadata,
you have to specify
both a key and a value.
You can edit this list of fixed
key metadata values for objects
if you have sufficient
permission to do so.
Cloud Storage uses identity and
access management and access
control lists to control access
to objects, including access
to the object's metadata.
If you'd like to know
more about access control,
check out our episode and
the related documentation.
The Cache-Control metadata can
specify two different aspects
of how data is served
from Cloud Storage--
if it can be cached and
if it can be transformed.
I won't say more about
Cache-Control here
because that'll be enough
for a future video,
but you can also find out more
in the documentation linked
below.
The Content-Disposition
metadata specifies
presentation information about
the data being transmitted.
Setting
Content-Disposition allows
you to control the presentation
of style of the content.
For example, determining
whether an attachment should
be automatically
displayed or whether some
form of action from the user
should be required to open it.
Check the links
in the description
to see the Content-Disposition
specification.
The Content-Encoding
metadata can
be used to indicate that
an object is compressed
while still maintaining the
object's underlying content
type.
For example, a text file
that is gzip compressed
can have the fact that
it's a text file indicated
in the Content-Type and the
fact that it's gzip compressed
indicated in Content-Encoding.
The Content-Language metadata
indicates the language
or languages that the
object is intended for.
Refer to ISO 639-1 language
codes for the supported values
of this metadata.
The most commonly set
metadata is Content-Type, also
known as media type.
This allows browsers to
render the object properly.
All objects of a
value is specified
in their Content-Type
metadata, but this value
does not have to match the
underlying type of the object.
For example, if the
Content-Type isn't specified
when the object gets uploaded
and it's not a common data
type, chances are it's going
to be something generic or just
wrong in the metadata.
Custom metadata are
like standard metadata,
except you can specify custom
metadata key/value pairs.
To create custom metadata, you
specify both a value and a key.
Once you have created a custom
metadata key/value pair,
you can delete the key
or change the value.
You can edit fixed-key
and custom metadata
from the REST API, gsutil, and
the Cloud Platform console.
Let's take a look
at the console.
Open the Cloud Storage browser
in the Cloud Platform console.
In the list of buckets,
click on the name
of the bucket that
contains the desired object
and navigate to the object.
Click the three dots for
more options associated
with the object.
Click Edit metadata.
In the overlay
window that appears,
make the desired
edits to the metadata.
For standard metadata
fields, edit the value.
Add your own custom
metadata by clicking
the plus sign Add Item button.
You can edit both the key
and the value of your custom
metadata.
Delete your custom metadata
by clicking the associated X.
Finally, click Save.
And now you know how to edit
metadata from the console.
But some metadata can't
be edited directly.
This metadata is set at the time
of object creation or rewrite.
As part of the object
creation or rewrite,
you can set some such
metadata, such as the storage
class of the object or
customer-supplied encryption
keys.
Other metadata is
automatically added
and can only be viewed,
such as the generation
number of the object or
the time of creation.
Find out more in the
docs linked below.
There's clearly a lot more
you can do about metadata,
but that's for a totally
different episode.
If you want to know about how
Cloud Storage uses metadata,
check out the links
in the description.
Don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of Cloud Storage.
See you next time.
[CHEERFUL MUSIC]